[Music]  i've taken lashes my whole life  to keep my family safe but they  will never  [Music]  you gotta go  that man escaped your plantation  single-handedly killed three  men  you might as well give up now he's smart  they say he's african royalty they call  him emperors if you can't take the heat  don't light the fuse  nobody called me because my granddaddy  was a kid  in me i trust yeah so you killed a bunch  of  ready to fight on wife night what to  bring him here for  ain't you got no manners the laundry  keeps it up  he got yourselves a rebellion i need you  to be the spark that lights the fuse  you're going to get yourself killed it's  the only way i can free my son  you got to get out of here you're not  just a slave anymore  you ever consider going the outlaw  business well i got the whole self  chasing me  i'm ready an outlaw  you